während des schlafens eine fremdsprache
lernen einen sportler trainieren oder
sogar großartige erfindung aus dürfte
genau an diesem spektakulären ziel
arbeiten forschungsteams weltweit der
us-wissenschaftler ende moritz hat eine
art traummaschine kreiert mit der er
sich in menschliche träume ein hacken
kann damit ist es ihm tatsächlich
bereits gelungen menschen kreativer zu
machen klicks um das feature gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivierte glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
technology review entstanden dem
technologie magazin des emmett dem
massachusetts institute of technology
und am ende gibt es ein exemplar für
euch kostenlos und der link ist auch in
der video beschreibung
das ist wirklich verrückt manche der
besten songs sind im schlaf entstanden
yesterday von den beatles satisfaction
von den rolling stones every breath you
take von police und es sind noch
unzählige mehr in traum sind wir
besonders kreativ und das will sich ein
forscher jetzt zunutze machen
auf der einen seite ist es ein ziemlich
gruseliges gefühl wenn man sich
vorstellt dass träume gezielt
manipuliert werden könnten dass sie
fremde menschen oder firmen unsere
träume hätten können
auf der anderen seite hätte es enorme
vorteile fachleute weltweit träumen
davon schlafphasen und träume zu
manipulieren um uns dadurch nicht nur
besser schlafen lassen sondern auch
nachhaltiges lernen und mehr kreativität
uns zu verschaffen ganz vorne mit dabei
ist der us-wissenschaftler er dem
horvitz vom mit media lab der die
menschen im schlaf kreativ werden lassen
will
mit der hilfe eines messgeräts trinkt er
tief in den schlaf seiner probanden und
probanden ein
hierfür reicht übrigens auch schon ein
kurzer mittagsschlaf anders als bei
vielen anderen traum forscherinnen und
forschern sind seine experimente und
messmethoden weder besonders aufwendig
noch teuer man kann es kaum glauben aber
sein messgerät besteht nur aus drei
fingerring und einem elektronischen
armband das seine versuchs
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer während
des schlafens tragen müssen
da zudem horvitz wir können ihnen einen
teil ihres kopfes zeigen den sie noch
nie gesehen haben
vor den versuchen werden die probanden
und probanden also verkabelt das armband
bist änderungen im muskeltonus der haut
leitfähigkeit und der herzfrequenz mit
kabeln und über bluetooth sind diese
sensoren mit einem smartphone genauer
mit einer app verbunden in der
vergangenheit standen vor allem zwei
schlafphasen im fokus der forschung der
sogenannten rem schlaf und der
tiefschlaf die abkürzung rem steht für
rapid eye movement es also für schnelle
augenbewegungen beim tiefschlaf messen
die forscherin längere langsame gehirn
werden beide phasen haben eine sache
gemeinsam denn sowohl im tiefschlaf als
auch im rem-schlaf treten träume auf
doch inhaltlich unterscheiden sich diese
wie man mittlerweile weiß im rem-schlaf
sind die träume er geschichten artig im
tiefschlaf sind diese wie gedanken doch
der wissenschaftler hat eine ganz andere
phase im visier
und zwar die phase des einschlafens also
den übergang zwischen wachen und träumen
er ist davon überzeugt dass diese phase
als eine art einfallstor genutzt werden
kann um sich in träume zu hacken diese
zu beeinflussen oder sogar zu
manipulieren konkret geht es ihm vor
allem um das sogenannte hawkeye stadium
er selbst bezeichnet es als einen zitat
halb klaren schlafzustand indem wir zu
träumen beginnen
der wissenschaftler ist davon überzeugt
dass das menschliche gehirn in dieser
übergangsphase ganz besonders frei
assoziiert bereits vor 24 jahren als 196
hatte ein japanischer wissenschaftler
eine neue stufigen skala zu dem prozess
des einschlafens entwickelt in der
fachsprache ist vom sogenannten core i9
stage die sprache genannt also nachdem
forscher selbst dori mit hilfe von eeg
messungen konnten wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler diese neuen stadien
unterscheiden das dritte stadium
bezeichnet die stufe bei dem unsere
gedanken in träumen übergeben dieses
fiese zucken im körper wer kennt das
nicht wenn man beim einschlafen noch mal
aufwacht und sich dann über die würm
bilder im eigenen kopf wundert also
waren wir gerade geträumt hat irgendwas
explodiert oder man ist gegen eine wand
gelaufen horowitz bezeichnet diesen
zustand als zehn minuten ag kommt nicht
das gehirn
sich also zwischen wahrheit und dem
luziden träumen das wird manchmal ja
auch als klartraum bezeichnet man ein
traum bei dem sich die träumte person
darüber bewusst ist dass sie träumt und
genau hier setzte der wissenschaftler an
und das ziemlich erfolgreich denn mit
seinen ersten experimenten der traum
inkubation hat der verblüffende
ergebnisse erzielt seine traum maschine
mit dem namen domino funktioniert
folgendermaßen das armband am handgelenk
der probandinnen und probanden erkennt
wann diese dabei sind einzuschlafen
genau dann wird eine audio message
abgespielt die die versuchs
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer vor dem
experiment selbst ausgewählt und
aufgenommen haben ein beispiel dafür
du bist dabei einzuschlafen denke an
eine gabel die app weiß zudem auch wann
die personen eingeschlafen ist und
spricht sie dann an das können
beispielsweise fünf minuten sein
dann fragt die app was denkst du und
auch die antwort der beteiligten
personen wird aufgezeichnet die app
lässt aber nicht locker und fragt immer
weiter erzähl mir mehr oder schlechte
oder bist du wache dieser zyklus wird
wiederholt etwa 45 minuten lang eine
schreckliche vorstellung für alle die
das einmaliges losen ihres wetters schon
kaum ertragen können dazu der
us-wissenschaftler dem horvitz obwohl
dieses ständige aufwachen sich sehr
anstrengend anhört beschreiben die
versuchsteilnehmer die erfahrung als
positive und entspannt und zudem war
diese traum intervention von erfolg
gekrönt denn alle sechs probanden haben
tatsächlich von gabeln geträumt und sich
mit der stimme aus der app unterhalten
der forscher adam horowitz ist
begeistert davon bisher hat man eeg
geräte gebraucht um das schlaf stadium
zu bestimmen jetzt genügt ein armband
das leder auch zu hause anwenden kann
und das ist wirklich ein meilenstein für
die traum forschung denn es ist noch
nicht lange her da waren schlaf
forscherinnen und forscher nicht nur auf
viele tausend euro teure geräte
angewiesen sondern auch auf menschen die
bereit waren eine gesamte nacht im
schlaflabor zu verbringen
somit könnte der traum forschung also in
naher zukunft ein enormer aufschwung
bevor stehen im übrigen ein
forschungsfeld das sich in der
vergangenheit als eher undankbar
erwiesen hat denn zum einen wird die
traum forschung immer noch eng mit
sigmund freud dem begründer der
psychoanalyse verknüpft seinen theorien
zufolge handelt
es sich bei träumen um verschlüsselte
botschaften des unterbewusstseins was
die traum forschung und ihren ruf zudem
erschwert sie gilt als wenig exakte
wissenschaft denn klar ist träume sind
schwer zu messen menschen erinnern sich
oft nicht besonders exakt an ihre träume
und außerdem ist es notwendig die
versuchs teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
aus ihren träumen zu wecken
das alles kann das ergebnis eines
experiments beeinflussen und trotz
seiner innovativen herangehensweise hat
auch adam horowitz mit diesen
herausforderungen zu kämpfen lassen sich
die neuen hobby stage des einschlafens
also wirklich so exakt bestimmen wie es
behauptet andere wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler bezweifeln genau das
so auch der mannheimer schlafforscher
michael schredl dieser hält es zwar für
gut möglich dass sich mit hilfe von
daten wie der herzrate variabilität und
der haut leitfähigkeit bestimmen lässt
in welcher schlafphase sich jemand
befindet hiermit meint michael schredl
die einschlafphase leichter schlaf der
tiefschlaf oder der rem-schlaf doch die
insgesamt neun horst ages sind seiner
ansicht nach nicht so einfach zu
bestimmen er sieht eine weitere
schwierigkeit und zwar ist es seiner
meinung nach zitat unklar ob die
probanden schon schlafen oder noch was
sind möglicherweise machen die personen
ja auch kurz auf wenn die stimme aus der
app mit ihnen spricht dennoch ist auch
der deutsche wissenschaftler michael
schredl sicher dass die traum forschung
in der zukunft spektakuläre erkenntnisse
mit sich bringen wird denn erst seit
kurzer zeit setzt sich die erkenntnis
durch dass das gehirn im schlaf weiter
arbeitet kognitive prozesse während des
schlafens könnten also mit hilfe der
forschung genutzt werden sprich es
scheint demnach nicht unrealistisch dass
unsere träume demnächst so beeinflusst
werden könnten dass dadurch unser wissen
wächst bestimmte fähigkeiten trainiert
werden oder aber unser wohlbefinden
gesteigert wird adam horowitz ist
jedenfalls ganz vorne bei diesem griem
hecking dabei bei einem experiment lisa
seine versuchs teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer von bäumen träumen dabei
wurde wieder dieselbe methode angewandt
wie auch beim kabel versuch danach
sollten die personen nicht nur einen
kreativitäts test machen sondern auch
eine kreative geschichte schreiben von
67 träumende menschen schrieben 45 eine
geschichte die direkt mit bäumen zu tun
hatte zudem waren die geschichten auch
kreativer als die der kontrollgruppe die
nur im wachen zustand an bäume gedacht
hat
als messlatte für kreativität warnte
horowitz die computerbasierte methode
mit der bezeichnung recherchen an diesem
ist wie stark sich begriffe und konzepte
in einem text auch über einzelne sätze
hinweg aufeinander beziehen
diese größe wird als maß für die
kreativität eines textes verwendet das
ergebnis hat möglicherweise mit dem rem
schlaf zu tun denn dieser ist
wahrscheinlich bedeutend für kreative
aufgaben charakteristisch für dieses
schlaf stadium ist dass die verbindung
zwischen dem hippocampus und cortex
getrennt ist dabei ist der hippocampus
für das lernen und das gedächtnis
zuständig somit werden gedächtnisinhalte
deutlich wilder kombiniert wenn die
kontrolle des hippocampus im rem-schlaf
nachlässt so entstehen also er absurde
oder verrückte ideen daher die
vernünftige instanz blockiert ist andere
hirn und traum forscherinnen und
forscher setzen auf die tiefschlafphase
die schweizerische wissenschaftlerin
katharina henke hat den nach
mittagsschlaf von rund 40 freiwilligen
genutzt um diesen 48 wortpaare
vorzuspielen
dabei waren jeweils immer ein reales
sowie ein fantasie wort beispielsweise
hofer haus oder walken insgesamt viermal
wurden diese wortpaare in der
tiefschlafphase vorgespielt die
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer konnten
sich zwar nach dem aufwachen nicht mehr
aktiv an die phantasie wort erinnern
dennoch wurden sie gefragt ob ein
treffer in einen schuhkarton passt
konnten sie das besser einschätzen als
die kontrollgruppe ja das ist schon
extrem verrückt das interesse an dieser
art von kaum forschung ist groß adam
horowitz selbst hat beispielsweise ein
angebot von einem us getränkehersteller
bekommt dieser hatte sich wohl erhofft
von der traum forschung zu profitieren
konkret wollte er die menschen da
draußen von seinen produkten träumen
lassen spooky das fand auch adam
horowitz und hat das angebot abgelehnt
er möchte mit seinen erkenntnissen gutes
bewirken wenn du menschen beispielsweise
gute träume gibt und sie waren glücklich
auf wieso sollte man das nicht tun
mangelware bisher ist allerdings die
finanzielle förderung für solche
forschung denn wie gesagt die traum
forschung hat ein schlechtes image
horror will selbst verwendet in seinen
förderanträgen deswegen auch nicht den
begriff träume sondern nachtgedanken in
zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion von
technology review ist dieses video
entstanden
exklusiv für dich zum zuschauer gibt es
jetzt eine ausgabe gratis kriegt dafür
einfach auf diesen link hier oder da ich
weiß jetzt gar nicht wo man hin gepackt
haben oder unten in die video
beschreibung es lohnt sich technology
review ist mega interessant und hier
geht es zu einem weiteren video das wir
mit der redaktion gemacht haben ewiges
leben möglich klick drauf wenn es euch
interessiert und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran